esta cosechadora atravesaba un pastizal
a unos 20 kilómetros de la línea del
frente con las fuerzas rusas en la
región del donbass cuando chocó con una
mina y quedó calcinada por las llamas un
recordatorio de los riesgos de cultivar
la tierra en un granero que se ha
convertido en una brutal zona de guerra
una bomba de casete combina se explota
en el aire y luego cubre una zona
determinada con pequeñas minas
antipersona después detonan al cabo de
un tiempo y si la gente las pisas
explotan
por estos motivos convencer a los
trabajadores de que recojan la cosecha
es una lucha constante
la gente no quiere a cosechar todos se
preocupan por sus vidas sus cosechadoras
y su equipo así que este problema es muy
grave problema de salud pero a pesar de
los riesgos algunos se ven impulsados a
trabajar la tierra por la austeridad de
la guerra
nueva dan miedo trabajar aquí pero es
una distracción es mejor que quedarse
sentado en casa y tener miedo y además
hay que ganar algo para vivir
ucrania representa el 10% del mercado
mundial de trigo pero el bloqueo de la
cadena de suministro ha creado una
crisis para los agricultores a
principios de agosto sintieron un alivio
al ver el primer cargamento de granos
salir de ucrania desde que rusia lanzó
su invasión a gran escala y bloqueó los
puertos en el sur del mar negro